[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
sur public sénat pour suivre les
questions d'actualité du sénat au
gouvernement des questions d'actualité
consacrée à la crise sanitaire du
coronavirus avec un dispositif
particulier ici au sénat un nombre très
raide très réduit de sénateurs des
distances de sécurité entre les
sénateurs dans l'hémicycle dix questions
seront posées au gouvernement avec la
présence du premier ministre et de
quelques ministres
d'abord des questions sur les hôpitaux
sous tension et emmanuel macron qui a
annoncé l'accélération de la production
d'équipements sanitaires de masques de
respirateurs avec la mobilisation des
industriels il aurait également des
questions économiques sur les aides aux
entreprises
et puis également sur le rôle des
assurances dans cette crise économique
qui s'annonce pour les entreprises le
rôle des assurances qui est parfois
pointés du doigt et puis vient un sujet
qui préoccupe beaucoup les sénateurs le
sénat représente les territoires il
s'agit de la couverture postale du
territoire puisque la poste a réduit
considérablement son activité pour que
six agents et bien ne soit pas
contaminée la conséquence est que
certains territoires ruraux se retrouve
sans couverture postale alors pour que
me parler de cette crise sanitaire
j'accueille laurence rossignol sénatrice
socialiste de l'oise
aujourd'hui les premiers patients d'île
de france ont commencé à être transférés
vers l'ouest notamment en bretagne on
voit que la vague est en train de
s'étendre cette vague qui est partie du
grand est elle est en train de s'étendre
même à la région capitale vous savez moi
je suis de l'oise les premiers cas
mortels un fouet aux approcher un petit
peu du micro les premiers cas vraiment
lourd en france qu'on a connus qu'ils
étaient des quatre personnes qui
n'avaient pas voyagé en chine qui
n'avaient pas être en italie qui n'est
pas être en contact avec qui que ce soit
apparemment ce sont deux personnes de
l'oise donc déjà depuis le 27 février
mon département nous avons nous sommes
en mode affrontement du gyrus déjà déjà
nous avons eu beaucoup de décès dont
beaucoup de gens malades et nos services
sanitaires sont halak en action depuis
déjà un mois maintenant
donc la vague elle continue
effectivement qu'on vous dit de monter
grand test aux trans ile de france bien
entendu qui m'a l'air d'être
particulièrement touchée en effet alors
la région capitale est touché et les
plus grands hôpitaux européens ont
alerté hier sur la pénurie de
médicaments qui pourraient manquer dans
les hôpitaux dans les jours à venir
notamment les médicaments nécessaires
pour la réanimation
qu'est ce que doit faire l'état français
pour éviter cette pénurie je crois que
ce qui manque déjà c'est du curare ce
qui est le produit qui est nécessaire
pour anesthésier les gens pour pouvoir
les un tube et donc pour les mettre en
réanimation
j'imagine que le gouvernement français
avait peut-être aussi un peu anticipé
parce que je crois que les hôpitaux ont
très bien anticipé le besoin de lits en
réanimation ça fait quand même plusieurs
semaines qu'il s'y prépare et les
produits qui vont avec
je n'ai pas de solution de ma place là
où je suis pour dire au gouvernement
français trouvez-nous du curare et soyez
efficace j'imagine qu'ils cherchent
certains estiment qu'il faut être plus
volontariste avec les industries
pharmaceutiques qui est réquisitionné
leur production ça pourrait être une
solution
oui bien sûr que la réquisition est
toujours une solution à condition
qu'elle n'ait pas d'effets sur nos
importations ce qui est aussi un des uns
des petits sujets quand on réquisitionne
après on pourra se poser la question on
devra se poser la question de la manière
dont on a laissé notre industrie
pharmaceutique se disperser partout sur
la planète et de la manière dont on a
créer nous même notre propre dépendance
en matière pharmaceutique aux autres
d'abord aux sociétés privées
et puis ensuite à beaucoup d'autres pays
est la question d'un pôle public du
médicament se fera partie des débats qui
devront être abordés
quand on sera dans la reconstruction
après la crise alors il ya une question
très importante également pendant cette
crise c'est la protection des femmes
le nombre de violences conjugales serait
en train d'augmenter pendant cette
période de confinement avec une hausse
de 30 30 % des signalements le
gouvernement a créé un numéro d' alerte
par sms le 114
c'est une bonne mesure
oui c'est bien c'est bien j'espère que
ce numéro accueille aussi les enfants
jeux parce que quand on parle violences
intrafamiliales il faut quand ces femmes
il faut penser aussi enfants d'ailleurs
il ya déjà eu un enfant qui
malheureusement est décédé des violences
commises dans 16 par son père je crois
donc femmes et enfants il faut que ce
numéro sera accessible aux enfants
j'ai peut-être une proposition à faire
un ministre blanquette comme pendant que
les enfants reçoivent des cours par
internet peut être ce serait bien qu'ils
aient un message qui s'affiche en cas de
violence voilà le numéro qu'il faut
appeler pour que le l'information
rentrer dans les maisons et pas
simplement qu'elle soit dépendante fait
que les gens puissent en sortir de la
maison
mais la priorité je crois que le
gouvernement là dessus et est mobilisée
c'est protéger les femmes et les enfants
de 7 ce confinement qui ne peut être
malheureusement qu'un facteur
d'accroissement et puis durant cette
séance de questions d'actualité
vous poserez une question sur les
difficultés d'accès à l'interruption
volontaire de grossesse de grossesse
pendant cette crise oui oui j'avais
attiré l'attention du ministre il ya
quinze jours quand on a voté les lois
d'habilitation en expliquant que déjà on
savait que les délais légaux dit vg
serait difficile à tenir pendant la
période est de confinement et de crise
sanitaire
le ministre met un peu de haut voyons
pas très bien ce que les faire ces
histoires de femmes enceintes dans le
débat sur les ordonnances et bien hier
est sorti un appel signé par plus d'une
centaine de médecins qui confirment ceux
qui m'avaient déjà été communiquées par
eux mêmes quelques temps avant qu'ils
ont besoin de trois mesures la première
un allongement des dettes de deux
semaines des délais légaux dit vg un
allongement de deux semaines de délai de
ivg médicamenteuses celle qu'on fait à
la maison et la suppression de la
deuxième consultation pour les mineurs
ce qui pourrait leur permettre de
satisfaire les demandes des femmes de
garantie avec sally vg sans se mettre
eux-mêmes hors la loi ce qu'ils sont
prêts à faire dit-il dans cet dans cet
appel est notre responsabilité est celle
du gouvernement celle du parlement c'est
de ne pas les amener à devoir étendre la
loi et on écoutera la réponse du
ministre de la santé à votre question
merci beaucoup laurence rossignol d'être
venu répondre à mes questions et
j'accueille maintenant catherine de
roche sénatrice les républicains du
maine-et-loire
catherine de roche vous vous allez
interroger le gouvernement sur la
ray sur la phase de déconfinement
comment on sort de cette période de
confinement oui en effet le
déconfinement il doit être anticipée il
peut être anticipée là on est dans
l'anticipation et nous souhaitons
demander au gouvernement où il en est
dans la réflexion comment ce phrase
déconfinement de façon progressive et
quels sont les tests qui seront
développées lors ce lors de ce
déconfinement et j'aurais également une
question sur les thèses puisqu'on entend
beaucoup de beaucoup de choses sur les
différentes sd et je voudrais avoir une
clarification de ce sujet alors on en
parlait avec laurence rossignol des
patients franciliens sont en train
d'être transférés dans l'ouest il ya
déjà eu des patients du grand est qui
ont été transférées notamment dans votre
département
au chu d'angers maintenant ce sont les
hôpitaux de l'ouest qui vont subir cette
vague et qui doivent tenir
oui ce que nous dit le directeur de la
rs des pays de la loire c'est qu'en
effet la vague arrive qu'il faut
s'attendre à une vague importante et
donc être vraiment prêts pour accepter
des patients on sait qu'il ya une
tension en termes de protection
individuelle certes mais aussi en
intentions en terme de matériel le
président de la république et hey
arrangé mais il donne des l'ennemi mais
pour arriver au maximum des productions
or on sait combien chaque jour compte
vu la progression très rapide de
l'épidémie justement y à ranger dans l'
usine comme mille président de la
république a annoncé une accélération de
la production de masques de respirateurs
avec une dotation de 4 milliards d'euros
à santé publié public france c'est un
effort suffisant selon vous c'est majeur
on voit qu'on a encore des
professionnels du soin qu'ils soient à
domicile dans les ehpad ou même des
professionnels de ville qui pour
l'instant ne sont pas équipés alors
qu'ils sont les plus exposés à la fois
pouvoir contaminé dépassé en six feux
sont porteurs du virus mais aussi à être
eux-mêmes contaminé certains en fait
d'ailleurs le prix de leur vie
merci beaucoup catherine de roche je
vous laisse regagner à l'hémicycle pour
le début de cette séance de questions
d'actualité je vais maintenant
accueillir martin lévriers sénateurs la
république en main en marche des
yvelines bonjour bonjour martin lévriers
alors
vous interroger sur l'union nationale
notamment l'union nationale de la classe
politique emmanuel macron a eu des mots
très durs hier envers je cite les
irresponsables qui voudraient faire des
procès alors qu'on n'a pas encore gagné
la guerre
les responsables politiques ne
respectent pas cette union nationale
grande majorité le respecte il faut le
dire clairement je pense qu'on a des
partis que je qualifierais d'extrémistes
rien de nouveau qui ne veulent pas le
respecter parce que c'est leur fond de
commerce ils vivent sur la pauvreté dont
kylie sur la peur et vivent sur la peur
quelque part le grenat virus je vais
violent mais les arrange et partant de
sa la désunion les arrangerait aussi le
chaos les arrange voilà mais la plupart
je veux je prends les républicains je
prends les socialistes je prends ce qui
se passe au sénat avec tous les partis
ici où il n'y a aucun problème d'une
entente nationale ou même titre qu'on
ait notre national au niveau des
entreprises à tous les niveaux au niveau
des français qui respecte le confinement
c'est ça qu'il faut respecter
aujourd'hui on doit être dans l'action
permanente par ce concours on court
après un virus qu'on ne connaissait pas
donc c'est la course effrénée mondiale
cette pandémie qui touche le monde
entier aujourd'hui donc c'est l'union
qui nous fera gagner cette bataille qui
est une bataille mondiale je le rappelle
donc les petites désunion qu'on a dans
ces parties qui ne méritent pas ne
mérite pas d'intérêt prendre alors le
premier ministre et le ministre de la
santé vont être auditionnés ce soir à
l'assemblée nationale dans le cadre
d'une mission d'information
du côté du sénat on va également
auditionné les ministres concernés par
cette crise sanitaire
c'est important de faire ces auditions
poursuivre le travail de l'exécutif
c'est absolument essentiel le rôle des
parlements pas du parlement que ce soit
le sénat où que ce soit l'assemblée
nationale est aussi de contrôler le
gouvernement
et l'action n'empêche pas le contrôler
la confiance n'empêche pas le contrôle
et bien heureusement et le contrôle du
contrôle permet aussi parfois des
évolutions notables qui peut être
intéressante pour tout le monde donc qui
dit contrôler ne dit pas aux positions
loin de là et moi je suis très fier que
les deux parlements fasse ce genre de
choses est que le gouvernement bien sûr
répondu oui immédiatement et accepte
avec
grande sévérité ce genre de débats qui
sont essentielles la démocratie et il
faudra attendre la rentrée pour une
commission denquête probablement sortons
de la crise sans contre la crise avant
tout alors je le disais les hôpitaux
franciliens sont sévèrement touchés en
ce moment la vague est vraiment en
ile-de-france comment ça se passe dans
votre département des yvelines martray
duriez traitant du département des
yvelines un département très tendues
depuis le début on a des gros problèmes
aujourd'hui mais comme tous les ans plus
tôt aux franciliens de stocks en
particulier de médicaments pour les
réanimations ça on le savait les le
nombre de livres on tient encore le coup
mais c'est très compliqué effectivement
d'accord est-ce que l'effort est assez
fort pour le pour l'hôpital
emmanuel macron à accélérer la
production de masques il accélère pour
nomades vous avez vu qu'il a débloqué
aujourd'hui par 4 milliards d'euros
donc c'est très important et c'est
urgent mais face à l'urgence on court et
la course est effréné etc nous gagnerons
au bout mais à chaque jour suffit sa
peine malheureusement donc on peut on
est en flux hypertendus oui il faut pas
tomber
alors il ya une urgence il ya une
urgence économique également avec un
besoin de soutien financier aux
entreprises
gérald darmanin a lancé une sorte de
corona ton un appel aux dons pour
soutenir notre économie est ce que c'est
une bonne initiative
tout ce jour 10 ils sont bonnes au même
titre que les responsables de grandes
entreprises ont décidé de faire un gros
d'un effort sur leur salaire à condition
qu'ils avaient qu'ils prennent de
chômage technique donc toutes ces
initiatives sont bonnes elles sont
urgents 12 ans d'une crise où l'avez
entendu tout le monde le dit qui est
supérieur à ce qui s'est passé pendant
la dernière guerre qui est supérieur à
toutes les étapes toutes les épidémies
pascal est mondiale donc oui toutes les
initiatives sont bonnes toutes les
initiatives de communion les uns avec
les autres sont indispensables
aujourd'hui et d'entre aide mais ce
qu'il ne faut pas être un peu plus
coercitif avec les plus fortunés par
exemple certains voudraient un isf
spécial corner coronavirus mais ça on y
viendra après la queer lille coercition
quand on est dans l'action ne sert à
rien on ne va pas à la guerre en
poussant les gens avec une baïonnette on
les vend les entraînements et nous
devons les entraîner à cette guerre
d'accord il faut inciter à être
solidaire envers les pouvoirs publics
il faut être solide à en voir plus et
tous les uns envers les autres et vous
verrez la question je pose d'ailleurs
gouvernement tout à l'heure concerne
justement cette solidarité la solidarité
de tous avec tous et c'est comme ça que
nous gagnerons ça n'est pas que l'état
contre ou avec les autres c'est tout le
monde avec tout le monde
merci beaucoup à fin février la cloche
vient de sonner
c'est le début de ces questions
d'actualité au gouvernement merci
[Musique]
internet
nous n'avons pas reçu d'observation je
n'en vois point on s'élance il est donc
adopté
monsieur le premier ministre et dame
madame monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues notre pays vit depuis re deux
semaines un peu plus une période de
confinement je tiens à saluer le civisme
nos compatriotes et savent que cette
épreuve doit permettre à tous nos
soignants de aussi préservé de sauver
des vies et c'est la manifestation de la
solidarité au service de tous et je sais
que l'ensemble de nos collègues
sénateurs qu'ils soient présents ou
derrière leur écran
le rôle et j'ai le regret nous faire
part du décès d'un ancien collègue paul
natali qui fut sénateur de la côte corse
de 1998 à 2005
si le premier ministre madame et
messieurs les ministres
il n'avait jamais été sénateur mais il a
siégé au moment du gouvernement dans
notre assemblée
j'ai bien souvenir de l'avoir accueilli
moi même comme président du sénat
c'était en novembre 2008 alors qu'il
était nommé ministre chargé du plan de
relance après la crise financière
cette et patrick devedjian
nous avions étaient ensemble au
gouvernement sous l'autorité du
président jacques chirac
c'était un gaulliste convaincu un homme
cultivé au fond par les dévoués à son
pays son département et à la veille qui
l'avait élu maire en 1983 promotion 83
auquel nous avions appartenu ensemble
ils étaient aussi fidèle très fidèle à
ses racines arméniennes dont il ne
supportait pas qu'on pu oublier le drame
je voulais tout simplement rappelé la
voix forte qu'il avait eue dans cet
hémicycle il avait une voix forte et au
travers de mes mots avoir en même temps
une pensée pour tous ceux qui se battent
en ce moment pour la vie et pour leur
vie en ce moment de crise je vous
propose avoir un moment à la fois de
recueillement et de solidarité
je vous remercie
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions de
contrôle au gouvernement comme vous le
voyez nous siégeons en effectif
restreint adapté aux contraintes
sanitaires en accord avec les présidents
de groupes politiques que je tiens
vraiment à remercier une fois encore
pour aller dire l'engagement leur
présence et nous aurons une conférence
des présidents la semaine prochaine
j'aurai l'occasion de leur dire mais je
voulais vraiment leur dire cela et en
témoigner devant tous ceux qui nous
regardent notre séance est donc
retransmise en direct sur public sénat
dont je salue et remercie les
journalistes et les techniciens
la parole est à notre collègue justin 10
days pour le groupe de l'union centriste
vous avez la parole mais chers collègues
merci président donc c'est au nom du
groupe centriste que ma question
concernera la poste mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues le groupe la poste vient
d'annoncer se recentrer sur ses missions
essentielles
en conséquence depuis lundi le courrier
n'est plus distribué que trois jours par
semaine
de plus la poste ne maintiens que 6% de
ses bureaux ouverts en horaires aménagés
au cas par cas
enfin de nombreux distributeurs de
billets de la banque postale ne sont pas
approvisionnés des conséquences de ce
qui ressemble à une démission sont
graves en milieu rural certaines
personnes se retrouvent totalement isolé
la distribution du courrier trois jours
sur six va fragiliser un peu plus la
presse écrite
sans parler du lien social et
d'informations qu'elles assurent près
des personnes âgées
une session bien plus compatible avec
l'idée que les français se faisait de ce
service public et d'une entreprise qui
communique sur sa proximité et son lien
avec les territoires encore plus grave
cette situation va couper les vivres à
certains de nos concitoyens
j'ai été interpellé par une personne
âgée qui n'a pour seule ressource que
l'argent qu'elle retire au guichet de la
poste
c'est aussi la situation de plus de 1,5
million d'allocataires des minima
sociaux qui viennent chaque mois retirer
leur espèce pour répondre à cette
urgence la banque postale va permettre
les retraits d'espèces en distributeurs
à partir du 4 avril au lieu du 7 et 250
bureaux de postes supplémentaires vont
être ouverts pour faciliter le retrait
au guichet comment ces mesures pourront
elles à être à la hauteur de l'enjeu
le retrait en dab en date pardon ne sera
d'aucune utilité si les dames ne sont
pas approvisionnés et les nouveaux
clichés ouvert ne représente qu'une
fraction des bureaux fermés
à l'heure où les gens n'ont plus
d'argent ou les commerçants commencent à
faire des ardoises ne portons pas
correctement protégé les agents de la
poste pour que le service soit rendu
normalement
pourquoi serait-elle plus exposées dans
les bureaux de poste que les commerçants
de bouche qui sont ouverts et d'études
pas possible au moins en zone rurale de
répartir les tournées restantes en les
programmant des lundis mercredis et
vendredis au lieu de les concentrer en
fin de semaine
je vous remercie merci pour vous
répondre la parole et à madame la
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances madame agnès
pannier rue nationale la parole madame
la ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice guinness vous avez raison la
poste fait partie de ces services qui
doivent permettre au pays de fonctionner
même dans cette période de confinement
et c'est notre devoir d'organiser ce
service indispensable à nos concitoyens
en protégeant au mieux également
les salariés de cette entreprise c'est
pour cela que au delà des 1600 bureaux
répartis sur l'ensemble du territoire
nous avons effectivement 250 bureaux de
plus qui vont dès la semaine prochaine
assurer la le paiement des prestations
sociales pour que ce soit fait dans de
bonnes conditions
la caisse d'allocations familiales
anticipera le versement de ces
prestations et les distributeurs devront
être fournis pour pouvoir effectivement
payés dès ce week end ses prestations
aux bénéficiaires
nous allons également demander sur la
base du bénévolat l'appui de postiers
qui sont aujourd'hui en télétravail pour
venir sur le terrain compléter ses
équipes parce que vous avez raison il
faut continuer à maintenir un lien
social ce lien social c'est celui de
tous les services comme veiller sur mes
patients mes parents cohésion ardoise et
c'est également ses services de
livraison de
médicaments et de repas à domicile en
particulier pour les plus vulnérables et
je veux vous dire ici que le
gouvernement est particulièrement
attentif à la situation le premier
ministre m'indiquer un instant qu'il
ferait le point cette semaine avec les
dirigeants de la poste pour veiller à ce
que il y ait un service sans faille sur
les territoires non seulement dans la
distribution du courrier non seulement
dans la distribution de la presse écrite
qui doit être renforcé en 2000
en début de semaine mais également dans
tous les services et notamment de mise à
disposition d'argents pour les plus
vulnérables
je vous remercie merci la parole et à
notre collègue martin lévriers pour
l'europe la république en marche vous
avez la parole mon cher collègue
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur gabriela tall secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'éducation de la
jeunesse et de la ligue est sûre
nationale pardon de la jeunesse la
pandémie que nous subissons mais chaque
jour en évidence le travail et
l'abnégation de tout le personnel
soignant qui est en première ligne mais
aussi l'indispensable travail de toutes
les personnes qui agissent au quotidien
souvent dans l'ombre pour faire
fonctionner une grande part de notre
économie à toutes ces femmes à toutes
ces sommes je veux leur dire merci
pour sortir de cette crise pour protéger
les autres nous demandons à chacun de se
confiner à tous ces français qui
acceptent la tente
nous devons aussi dire merci et parmi
tous ces citoyens nombreux s'unissent et
invente des solutions à des
problématiques tourner vers les plus
démunis vers les plus vulnérables vers
ceux qui sans aide ne pourrait se
relever de cette crise nous pouvons les
laisser seuls et c'est pour ça
comprenons le besoin de les fédérer
vous avez monsieur le ministre lancée
lundi dernier la réserve civique
qu'ovide 19 au travers de la plate forme
je veux aider point gouv.fr elle doit
permettre à tous ceux qui le peuvent et
qui le souhaitent de donner de leur
temps
cet espace d'engagement a été construit
en lien avec les associations
humanitaires et aux côtés des
collectivités publiques de leur
structure il doit permettre de faire
état de leurs besoins de renforts dans
quatre domaines principaux l'aide
alimentaire et l'aide d'urgence
lagarde exceptionnel d'enfants le lien
avec les personnes fragiles isolées la
solidarité de proximité
monsieur le ministre j'aurai donc trois
questions combien de nouveaux bénévoles
avez vous enregistré sur cette plate
forme depuis son lancement
à titre personnel je connais des jeunes
qui souhaitent porter main forte mais ne
trouve pas de mission dans leur commune
comment peuvent-ils être utile et enfin
quelles missions auront les préfets
seront ils les traits d'union entre
offre et demande et inciteront t-il les
associations à saisir leurs offres de
mission je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole et secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur martin lévriers et le début de
cette crise sanitaire le président de la
république nous a appelés à relever ce
défi en solidaire plutôt qu'en solitaire
et à inventer de nouvelles solidarités
dans un moment d'inquiétude dans un
moment d'angoissé dans un moment de
confinement où beaucoup de français sont
isolés parfois n'ont pas la possibilité
d'avoir du lien la possibilité de sortir
de chez eux
aider les luttes cette crise nous avons
réuni avec olivier ferrand avec jean
michel blanquer avec christelle du boss
les grandes associations de solidarité
de notre pays pour faire le point avec
elle et que nous ont-elles dit que
évidemment 80 à 90% des activités
associatives dans notre pays sont
suspendus du fait du confinement et
c'est bien normal mais qu'il y à des
activités qui ne peuvent être suspendus
tout simplement parce qu'elles sont
vitales pour bon nombre de nos
concitoyens on parle beaucoup en ce
moment des supermarchés des courses il
ya des français qui ne peuvent pas aller
faire leurs courses faute de moyens
qu'ils ont l'habitude malheureusement de
s'alimenter via un libre service social
j'ai un point de distribution des restos
du coeur
or c'est libre aux services sociaux ces
points de distribution sont généralement
animé par des bénévoles qui parfois dans
leur majorité ont plus de 70 ans et avec
beaucoup de responsabilités les
associations ont demandé à ses bénévoles
âgées de rester chez eux confiner le
plus possible et donc le premier besoin
que nous on fait remonter les
associations c'est un besoin de
ressources bénévoles pour continuer ses
actions c'est le sens du lancement de la
plateforme je veux aider point gouv.fr
et de la réserve civique est ce que nous
constatons une dizaine de
jours après son lancement c'est un élan
de solidarité absolument exceptionnel et
sans doute inédit dans un temps si court
dans notre pays ce que je peux vous
annoncer
c'est que 250 mille français ont déjà
rejoint la réserve civique pour venir en
aide sur le terrain au plus haut plus
aux plus démunis cinquante mille sont
déjà engagés dans des missions vous
poser une question pour des jeunes
notamment qui serait dans des
collectivités dans des communes où il
n'ya pas de missions qui sont proposés
comme on ne peut être utile est d'abord
moi je veux rappeler un message le
premier la première marque de solidarité
c'est de rester chez soi en solidarité
avec les soignants qui se battent en
solidarité avec nos concitoyens qui sont
infectés sur la plateforme tout français
peut télécharger un kit ce que nous
avons réalisé avec l'association voisins
solidaires qui permet de s'engager à
l'échelle de son immeuble à l'échelle de
sa rue il ya déjà eu cinq cent mille
téléchargements doit penser à conclure
et donc tous les français peuvent
s'engager en proximité
par ce biais pour merci merci beaucoup
la parole est à notre collègue le
président jean marc gabouty pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique et
social européen
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président président madame la secrétaire
d'état auprès du ministre de l'économie
et des finances bien évidemment
l'impératif sanitaire est totalement
prioritaire mais le risque d'une grave
crise économique est devant nous le
gouvernement n'est totalement conscient
et a réagi très rapidement avec un
premier train de mesures consistant et
pertinente
le dispositif mis en place mériterait
cependant d'être amplifié compléter et
parfois précisé
j'ai deux questions à vous poser madame
la ministre pour les prêts bancaires aux
entreprises avec une enveloppe de
garanties de l'état de 300 milliards le
gouvernement communique avec le slogan
audacieux et incitatif prenez dans votre
banque
le prêt garanti par l'état le libellé
suppose une certaine forme
d'automaticité pouvez vous confirmer que
les banques ne peuvent pas refuser de
manière directe ou détournés l'octroi de
ces prêts dès lors que leurs clients
répondent aux conditions d'éligibilité
et avez vous prévu un encadrement des
taux d'intérêts hors rémunération de la
garantie
ma deuxième question porte sur le fonds
de solidarité d'un milliard d'euros qui
sera majoré de 200 millions par les
compagnies d'assurance
grâce à la crise sanitaire et aux
mesures de confinement qui entraîne un
fort ralentissement des activités
économiques et des particuliers
les assurances sur les 40 à 50 milliards
d'indemnisations au titre des dommages
en année pleine ont économisé entre 3 et
5 milliards
c'est un ordre de grandeur pensez vous
que leur participation annoncée de 200
millions d'euros soit à la hauteur
ne doit-on pas aller vers un fonds de
solidarité beaucoup plus ambitieux qui
pourrait prendre en charge même de
manière très partielle les pertes
d'exploitation des entreprises et les
pertes de revenus des indépendants
artisans commerçants et professions
libérales pour vous répondre
secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre de
l'économie et des finances mme panis rue
nachi vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur gabouty vous avez
raison de souligner l'importance du plan
qui a été mise en oeuvre par l'état pour
accompagner les entreprises et en
particulier les plus petites d'entre
elles
ce plan repose sur trois piliers le
chômage partiel le report des
cotisations sociales et fiscales
catcheur piliers le fonds de solidarité
et la possibilité d'obtenir des
financements bancaires garantis par
l'état à hauteur de 90%
ces 300 milliards d'euros de
financements bancaires garantis vont
permettre effectivement aux banques de
manière quasi automatique sur la base
d'instructions que nous avons établies
et discuter avec les banques de
prolonger et de garantir des lignes de
trésorerie pour des entreprises qui
auraient une notation supérieure à un
certain niveau par rapport la notation
banque de france je veux ici précisé que
la notation banque de france a été
bloqué dans sa situation avant crise de
manière à ce qu'il n'y ait pas deux
difficultés liées effectivement à
l'impact de la crise donc on gèle la
situation et pour toutes les entreprises
qui sont en bonne santé avant la crise
alors le prêt doit être donnée de
manière quasi automatique et c'est ce
que nous sommes en train d'organiser
avec les banques sur les entreprises qui
avait déjà des difficultés de trésorerie
sans nécessairement être dans des
procédures de sauvegarde ces entreprises
là feront l'objet d'un examen ou la
médiation du crédit interviendra pour
trouver des solutions de compromis
équilibré enfin il ya une troisième
catégorie d'entreprises sont les
entreprises en difficulté celle là elles
doivent répondre aux critères européens
et c'est pour cela que nous travaillons
à un plan spécifique qui mobilisera
notamment le vitesse sur les assurances
très vite 200 millions dans le fonds de
solidarité
pourquoi pas sur les pertes
d'exploitation parce que moins d'une
entreprise sur deux ont une assurance
sur la perte d'exploitation ils se sont
souvent les plus rose qui ont cette
assurance donc ce serait relativement
inégal mais là où vous avez raison c'est
que nous pensons que les assurances
doivent elles être doivent aller plus
loin et c'est pour cela que bruno le
maire les mobilise notamment sur le fait
de prolonger les contrats quand bien
même les entreprises auraient du mal à
payer leurs primes d'assurance je vous
remercie monsieur le président gabouty
oui merci madame ministre les
difficultés des entreprises sont devant
nous à court terme il y aura d'immenses
besoins de trésorerie vous avez répondu
même si l'enveloppé 300 milliards risque
peut-être d'être insuffisante
mais demain leur pont économique
souhaitée dépendra la santé financière
des entreprises indispensables aux
adaptations innovation et à la relance
des investissements productifs pour les
assurances étaient toutes les
entreprises que je visais non pas celles
qui avaient déjà une assurance perte
d'exploitation dans un fonds spécifique
merci la parole est à notre collègue
cathy apourceau poly pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes avaient la parole mme asha
collègues
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre mes chers collègues le
président de la république a annoncé une
dotation exceptionnelle de 4 milliards
d'euros pour financer les commandants
médicaments respirateurs et en masque
produit chez nous par nos entreprises il
était temps les masques blouses et gants
arrivent au compte-gouttes il faut bien
le dire est désormais les médicaments
dans le curare commence à manquer les
mesures tardive annoncé par votre
gouvernement ne produiront
malheureusement malgré l'urgence pas
d'effet immédiat
madame la ministre il y a beaucoup
d'angoissé dans nos populations de peur
chez ceux et celles qui courageusement
chaque jour soigne les aides soignants
les infirmiers les médecins et
pharmaciens ils nous lancent de
véritable sos pour les aider à trouver
des solutions
les maires les élus le secteur
associatif se mobilisent pour aider
quotidiennement que dire des hôpitaux et
pat qui se démène dans des conditions
difficiles partout dans nos territoires
que dire des salariés qui travaillent
pour servir et faire vivre notre pays et
qui ne sont pas protégés que dire de
celles et de ceux qui travaillent alors
que leur activité n'est pas nécessaire
en ce moment quand allez-vous
réquisitionner les entreprises pour
fabriquer les médicaments nécessaires
comme le curare la morphine et l'eau et
l'oxygène quand allez-vous mettre les
moyens nécessaires pour produire les
tests massivement à l'ensemble de la
population comme le recommande depuis le
début le ms je vous remercie pour vous
répondre la parole est toujours à madame
la secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
de l'économie et des finances madame la
ministre
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice apourceau poly 4
milliards d'euros c'est effectivement
l'enveloppent massif qui est aujourd'hui
mise à disposition des hôpitaux pour
permettre de s'approvisionner en
matériel complémentaire mais je crois
que le ministre de la santé a été très
clair sur le plan qui a été anticipé et
mis en oeuvre depuis le début de cette
crise pour approvisionner l'ensemble des
hôpitaux l'ensemble des centres
hospitaliers à un moment où les
consommations de masques de gel
hydroalcoolique deux médicaments sont
multipliées par dix parfois par sens
parfois par mille au plan mondial
donc le sujet n'est pas d'aller
réquisitionnés ou d'aller nationaliser
ce n'est pas ça qui va permettre de
fabriquer plus de masques ou plus de gel
hydroalcoolique
le sujet aujourd'hui c'est d'entraîner
notre industrie comme nous sommes en
train de le faire
comme nous sommes en train de le faire
en ayant porté la production de masques
de 13 5 millions en france à plus de 40
millions au mois d'avril
comme nous sommes en train de le faire
en mobilisant le réseau d'achat
notamment santé publique france qui a
acheté plus d'un milliard de masques et
aujourd'hui qui est étayée par des
acheteurs privés
près de 150 qui sont en appui pour
équiper l'ensemble des français et comme
nous sommes également en train de le
faire avec le gel hydroalcoolique
puisque nous avons multiplié par dix par
10 la production de gel hydroalcoolique
et nous allons construire en 50 jours
autant de respirateurs que la france en
a produit en trois ans ça ce sont les
faits et ça permet d'accompagner
effectivement la montée en puissance de
nos soignants que je veux ici remerciés
pour leur travail remarquable pour leur
présence sans faille sur le terrain et
c'est cette deuxième ligne qui
effectivement est au travail derrière
eux qui doit aujourd'hui permettre
toutes ses réalisations sur la
protection des salariés
peut-être deux propos si je puis me
permettre d'abord le ministère du
travail du travail et l'abordé protocole
très précis pour les protéger et
deuxièmement en trois semaines nous
avons élaboré de nouveaux masques en r&d
ils sont aujourd'hui en production
et ça aussi permettra de protéger
l'ensemble des français
je vous remercie madame la sénatrice
vous avez 35 secondes
oui j'ai bien entendu vos propos madame
la ministre qui ne sont d'ailleurs
rassurant vous n'avez pas fait ce qu'il
fallait en temps et en heure je vous le
dis vous avez pris des rocades tard
considérable mais peut-être que si
effectivement il ya un nouveau pic
cet hiver on sera peut être prêt 1 mais
enfin la situation est dramatique
demain il vous faudra rendre des comptes
aux soignants mais aussi à notre
population
il faut changer de logiciel madame la
ministre l'urgence vitale exige de
substituer à vos dérives libérales
le choix de l'intérêt général les
réquisitions et les nationalisations
sont la voie du bon sens la voie du
salut
et vous pouvez vous pouvez changer de
braquet en rétablissant d'urgence lisf
par ordonnance je vous remercie
merci la parole est à notre collègue
didier marie pour le groupe socialiste
et républicain la parole mon cher
collègue
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres cher collègue
madame la secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie et des finances
notre pays confronté à la crise ducobu
19 connaît une situation inédite et
inquiétante tant sur le plan sanitaire
qu'économique mais mesures prises pour
freiner puis stoppé la propagation du
virus sont prioritaires est nécessaire
mais elle frappe aussi très durement nos
entreprises et leurs salariés qu'elle
ait stoppé ou réduit leur activité elles
subissent toutes d'importantes pertes
d'activités mettant en cause jusqu'à
leur survie le gouvernement a pris des
dispositions exceptionnelles pour
endiguer cette catastrophe économique et
sociale
elles sont les bienvenus malgré cela
nombre d'entreprises en particulier des
commerces artisans très petites et
moyennes entreprises craignent de ne
pouvoir réussir à y faire face
beaucoup se sont tournés vers leurs
assureurs qui leur répondent ne rien
pouvoir faire pour les soutenir car les
cas de pandémie sont systématiquement
exclus des polices d'assurance elle ne
l'est indemniserait pas plus pour la
plupart d'entre elles si l'état de
catastrophe naturelle
tel qu'il existe et est reconnue ne
couvrant pas les pertes d'exploitation
sans dommages à l'appareil productif
aussi madame la ministre a situation
inédite réponse inédite
comptez-vous au nom de l'urgence
modifier le code des assurances et
déclarer un état de catastrophe
naturelle et sanitaires en élargissant
les conditions d'indemnisation perte
d'exploitation sans dommages aux biens
matériels
comptez vous invoquez un impérieux motif
d'intérêt général et saisir le conseil
constitutionnel pour qu'ils
reconnaissent la validité d'une nouvelle
loi y compris rétroactive au 1er jour du
confinement là même la ministre
agnès pannier rue du chai vous répondre
à la question de notre collègue didier
marie merci monsieur le merci monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur marie
vous poser la question de la manière
dont nous allons pouvoir venir au
secours des très petites entreprises au
fond et la réponse nous l'avons trouvée
c'est le fonds de solidarité
fonds de solidarité qui vise les très
petites entreprises de moins d'un
million d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
qui visent des entreprises qui ont perdu
50 % de leur chiffre d'affaires au mois
de mars qui vise les entreprises qui
seront en difficulté au mois d'avril et
qui vise les entreprises qui ont dû
fermer pour des motifs réglementaires
par exemple et là effectivement les
assureurs sont au rendez vous ils sont
au rendez vous plus qu'ils abandonneront
il a bonne abonde euros à hauteur de 200
millions d'euros ce fonds
et cet argent on sait où il ira il ira à
ces très petites entreprises
il leur permettra à hauteur de 1500
euros dès les premiers jours d'avril de
pallier les difficultés auxquelles elles
sont font face au delà de des reports de
cotisations sociales et fiscales que
nous leur avons déjà accordés ça c'est
concret ça c'est rapide
ça nous paraît plus efficace et plus
rapide qu'une mesure qui viendrait sous
l'égide les dunes d'un retour sur une
jurisprudence constitutionnelle qui est
l'amour et autres rétroactivité et qui
serait très fragile juridiquement qui
prendrait du temps et qui ne serait pas
au rendez vous au moment où les
entreprises sont en train de souffrir
sur leur trésorerie
donc nous avons fait ce choix c'est un
choix pragmatique c'est un choix qui
engagent les assureurs et je souhaite
comme vous que les assureurs aille plus
loin
qu'ils aillent aussi sur les cotisations
liées aux sur les primes d'assurance des
contrats pour les entreprises qui
aujourd'hui ont du mal à payer ses
primes d'assurance qu'ils aillent plus
loin aussi dans les efforts qu'ils
peuvent faire sur ce fonds de solidarité
qui pourrait être prolongée au delà du
mois de mars comme nous pouvons
l'anticiper je pars et je regrette
votre réponse madame la ministre car
nous pensons effectivement qu'une loi
aurait pu être envisagé pour que les
assurances couvrent les pertes
d'exploitation sans dommages de bon
nombre d'entreprises
mais puisque
vous considérez que ce n'est pas
possible peut-être pourriez-vous
envisager une contribution spéciale
temporaire des assurances comme en 2010
est de telle sorte que celle qui
collecte 2,1 milliards d'euros par an au
titre du risque d'opa d'exploitation
puisse aller au delà des 200 millions
que vous avez évoquées merci par l'état
de notre collègue emmanuel capus pour le
groupe les indépendants vous avez la
parole vous chers collègues
merci monsieur le président dans cette
crise les soignants sont en première
ligne
je tiens bien évidemment à saluer leur
professionnalisme et leur dévouement
je tiens aussi comme vous l'avez fait
monsieur le président a salué tous nos
concitoyens qui respectent les consignes
qui restent confinés chez eux
il contribue également à endiguer
l'épidémie
au delà je voudrais saluer tous les
français qui continue de remplir leur
mission
je pense aux caissières aux policiers
aux militaires aux éboueurs aux
fonctionnaires aux routiers aux
agriculteurs et à tous ceux tous ces
professionnels qui continuent à
travailler malgré les conditions
dégradées pour mener la guerre contre le
virus
notre pays a besoin que chacun soit à
son poste
la continuité des services est
indispensable au fonctionnement notre
pays cela vaut particulièrement pour nos
services publics
je partage à cet égard l'attachement à
la continuité du service postal dans nos
territoires ruraux qui a été évoqué il
n'est pas acceptable que des postes
ferment ou que le courrier et la presse
ne soit plus distribué c'est souvent
aujourd'hui le seul lien avec
l'extérieur notamment pour les plus âgés
l'heure est à la mobilisation générale
la france a besoin que chacun soit à son
poste pour que chacun puisse se nourrir
se chauffer s'éclairer l'unité nationale
c'est le geste barrière de nos
institutions
alors madame la ministre vous pouvez
vous nous assurer que dans les semaines
qui viennent la continuité des services
indispensables à la population sera
assuré et de façon plus précise sur un
sujet qui tient à mme au coeur de
langevin que je suis pour assurer la
continuité alimentaire encore faut-il
qu'il y ait des producteurs
à cet égard les horticulteurs
aujourd'hui vont devoir jeter leur
production ma seconde question très
simple est donc la suivante pour leur
donner de l'air pourriez-vous les
autoriser à commercialiser leurs plants
potagers qui sont les aliments des mois
prochain merci pour vous répondre la
parole est à madame agnès pannier une
hache et secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'économie des finances
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs blessures le
sénateur qui a pu d'abord je veux
répondre à votre deuxième question
puisque dans le cadre des arbitrages que
nous venons de récemment rendre la vente
de plants potagers considéré comme un
achat de première nécessité et donc je
veux vous le dire ici par ailleurs
évidemment il va nous travaillons à la
continuité des services comment ils
travaillent en faisant le bilan avec
chaque filière de façon à voir quels
sont les grains de sable qui empêchent
cette continuité ces grains de sable on
les connaît c'est la logistique et
l'approvisionnement
c'est la capacité pour les salariés à
exercer leur métier et c'est la crainte
qu'ils peuvent avoir légitimement de
l'exercer dans les meilleures conditions
sanitaires
c'est pour cela que le ministère de la
santé travaille avec le ministère de tra
du travail a précisé très exactement les
conditions dans lesquelles c'est ce
travail doit être exercée a rappelé
comment les gestes anti ben les gestes
barrières et les mesures de
distanciation peuvent être mis
effectivement en place dans des
conditions de travail
comment on peut équiper l'ensemble des
salariés ça peut être des plaques de
plexiglas qui sépare et qui distancie
les personnes dans un commerce le client
du caissier par exemple ça peut être
d'autres mesures et nous travaillons
filière par filière à accompagner ces
mesures nous y travaillons aussi en
mettant à disposition sur une plateforme
gérée par la direction générale des
entreprises un certain nombre de
matériaux de protection je pense au gel
hydroalcoolique qu'ils peuvent acheter
directement je pense à des masques je
pense aux masques textile que nous
sommes en train de produire
et vous interrogez à raison de quatre
cent quatre-vingt mille masques textile
par jour lors comme ils sont
réutilisables
ce sont des productions qui sont en
réalité massive donc voilà très
concrètement toutes les façons d'assurer
la continuité du service dans notre pays
mieux capter quelques secondes non 5
secondes
merci pour les horticulteurs et pis pour
les passes c'est vrai que c'est ça ta
touche malheureusement les territoires
ruraux les plus isolées merci je veux ma
parole à madame catherine de roche pour
le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole ma chère collègue si
dans monsieur le ministre un constat
l'attention sur les protections
individuelles sur les matériels lourds
les restaurateurs les médicaments alors
certes les masques commandés arrive mais
ils sont pour l'instant réservée par
priorité aux personnels soignants au
contact notamment dix malades
hospitalisés mais peut encore sur le
domicile l'ehpad où les soins de ville
et sur les matériels président de la
république et ranger a annoncé la mi-mai
pour le le production maximale mais
chaque jour qui passe est un jour qui
compte des questions la première
les essais cliniques pourquoi ne pas
envisager d un essai clinique sur des
médicaments type hydroxy chloroquine
mais par les médecins de ville sur des
formes plus modérée et des patients plus
jeunes pour éviter une hospitalisation
deuxième point comment seront indemnisés
les professionnels de santé qui n'est ou
dentistes qui ont fermé leur cabinet
mais qui participent à la réserve
sanitaire ou aux urgences et dont les
assurances couvrent mal la perte
d'exploitation est troisième point celui
du déconfinement celui ci il peut il
doit être anticipée et il doit être
réussie pour éviter une deuxième vague
comment l'envisagez-vous et dans ceux
des confinement quid des tests on entend
un test sérologique rapides annoncé à
rennes les laboratoires départementaux
des conseils départementaux sont prêts à
apporter leur part dans les tests mais
ils n'ont toujours pas d'accord du
gouvernement
donc un message aussi monsieur le
ministre soyez ferme sur le confinement
nous sommes derrière vous en effet c'est
pour l'instant notre meilleur atout de
protection donc pas de dérogation même
pendant les vacances et surtout vraiment
soutien aux policiers qui vont dans des
quartiers difficiles assuré ce
déconfinement et puis de
l'assouplissement du décloisonnement pas
de tati youn ri si je puis dire
administratives qui freinent les choses
sachez le le sénat et notre groupe il
est là pour être le porte-voix des
territoires collectivités aider ceux
celles et ceux qui sont au contact des
patients risquent parfois leur vie mais
absolument pas dans la polémique
pour vous répondre la parole et à
olivier verront ministre des solidarités
de la santé ou la parole monsieur le
ministre
merci monsieur le président madame la
sénatrice catherine de roche merci pour
vos questions je vais tâcher de répondre
à la plupart d'entre elles
d'abord vous dire qu'il n'ya pas de
vacances pour le virus et donc il n'y a
pas de vacances pour le confinement et
là je veux être extrêmement clair nous
voulons être extrêmement clair sur le
fait que ce n'est pas parce qu'ils
adhéraient des vacances que tout d'un
coup les français peuvent quitter leur
lieu de confinement pour aller vers
d'autres lieux je comprends les
difficultés que cela représente pour les
trans est d'être confiné depuis
plusieurs semaines nous encore une fois
il y va de la vie des français de la
santé de nos concitoyens
j'ai indiqué hier que l'étude anglaise
montré que toutes les 10 minutes de
confinement nous sauvons une vie dans
notre pays et ça va aller en
s'accélérant
deuxième chose vous posez la question
des tests rapides et notamment les tests
rapides breton je voulais vous rassurer
les tests rapides de cette entreprise
bretons font l'objet d'une saisine et
d'une commande publique
cinq cent mille pour cinq cent mille
euros je crois de test nous sommes
de manière à pouvoir ex vérifier que ces
tests correspondent à tous les critères
attendus de qualité en termes de de
sensibilité de spécificités du rendu des
examens et nous avons demandé à
l'entreprise de nous produire le maximum
de test dès qu'elles le pourraient sitôt
que nous aurons qualifié ces tests là
donc nous sommes maintenant dépendant
des chaînes de production pas avant fin
avril je crois sans vous dire de bêtises
mais évidemment partout dans le monde je
l' ai déjà dit dès qu'il ya des tests
efficaces qui sont produits c'est encore
mieux quand ils sont français sans doute
encore mieux quand ils sont bretons
diront certains nous les achetons pour
pouvoir les fournir au marché français
vous dire sur les études cliniques
oui madame la sénatrice il ya non pas
une ni deux mais au moins trois études
cliniques qui teste différents
médicaments en prophylaxie sur les
formes peu sévères avec des études
contre placebo des études contre
d'autres formes de traitements il une
étude qui démarre à angers qui teste
vide roxy chloroquine il n' études à
montpellier qui a démarré qui teste
l'hydroxyde chloroquine et la bithérapie
roxy chloroquine azithromycine dans les
formes légères peu symptomatiques et il
ya une étude en prophylaxie qui est en
cours d'examen du cbp pour vérifier
qu'elle correspond aux critères de
règles éthiques donc nous nous sommes
pardon pour l'expression à fond sur les
études dès que nous pouvons en conduire
et qu'elles peuvent nous apporter des
nouvelles importantes
enfin sur la question je crois c'était
des libéraux de santec m'avait posé la
question je leur ai indiqué hier que des
négociations étaient ouvertes avec
l'assurance maladie pour que les
libéraux puissent bénéficier d'une
compensation de perte de revenus c'est
normal et ils pourront en bénéficier
pour ceux qui le souhaitent même de
dispositifs d'abord les conditions
opérationnelles pratiques sont à voir
avec l'assurance maladie
mais j'en ai informé personnellement la
plupart des syndicats libéraux déjà hier
merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est aux questeurs rémy
pointereau pour le groupe les
républicains n'avaient la parole
monsieur tout dire merci monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les mini
ses chers collègues ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'économie des
finances madame la ministre nous savons
tous que la priorité aujourd'hui est la
sécurité sanitaire et la santé de nos
concitoyens
malgré tout plusieurs sujets d'ordre
économique doivent être et devront être
rapidement appréhendé le premier
concerne le fonctionnement de la poste
et serait été dit par ma collègue la
fermeture
de nombreux clichés et une distribution
du courrier seulement trois jours de
suite par semaine est inacceptable car
elle ne correspond pas au principe de
continuité du service public des
entreprises où des personnes isolées en
milieu rural notamment madame la
ministre que comptez vous faire pour
garantir l'application et le respect du
principe de continuité du service public
notamment de la poste le deuxième sujet
concerne la situation économique des
petits commerçants la crise qu'il
traverse et exposé de plus en plus au
risque de faillite pendant qu'on leur
demande de fermer boutique à leur
activité n'est pas jugé prioritaire les
grandes surfaces continuent de vendre
des produits qui ne relèvent pas des
besoins primaires
quid des géants du e-commerce telle
amazon pour qui la crise constitue une
aubaine économique sans égal et la
distorsion de concurrence entre commerce
numérique et physique déjà importante
s'en retrouve renforcé
madame la ministre envisagez vous de
prendre des mesures pour rééquilibrer la
situation de sorte à ce que le commerce
de proximité ne soient pas lésés et
puissent être compensées pour cette
période de confinement et enfin le
troisième sujet concerne les pertes
d'exploitation des artisans commerçants
tpe et professions libérales qui
désespèrent de la situation d'autant que
les contrats d'assurances ne couvre pas
ses pertes
aussi l'état a proposé 300 milliards de
garanties de prêts bancaires
c'est une bonne chose madame la ministre
pourquoi ne pas confier ne serait ce que
5 % de ce montant aux compagnies
d'assurance pour leur demander de
couvrir les pertes d'exploitation des
nombreux professionnels en détresse au
titre des catastrophes sanitaires
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et table même unissent agnès
pannier rue nasheed les paroles
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur point trop
s'agissant de la question du
fonctionnement de la continuité de
service de la poste nous avons éclairé
cette situation est effectivement vous
avez raison le gouvernement va se
mobiliser pour assurer que tous les
jours deux
semaine il y ait cette continuité de
service que la presse soit continue à
être distribuées y compris en début de
semaine et que les services de proximité
que la poste assure notamment auprès des
plus vulnérables et auprès des personnes
âgées continue également d'être assurée
avec cette idée que dans les zones
rurales
il est particulièrement important que
cette continuité de service et lieu
s'agissant des assurances c'est
également une question qui a été posée
sur ses bancs la perte d'exploitation je
le redis la réponse que nous y apportons
qui est une réponse rapide immédiate les
tpe peuvent aujourd'hui déposer leurs
dossiers pour bénéficier d'une première
tranche de 1500 euros qui sera payé dans
les prochains jours qui va venir je
dirais complémenter des pertes de
revenus des pertes d'exploitation de
manière immédiate elles pourront
bénéficier de 2000 euros additionnel
nous le mettons en place avec l'appui
des collectivités locales je veux
remercier ici les régions qui ont
totalement joué le jeu dans cet exercice
et des autres collectivités locales qui
se signalent spontanément pour
accompagner ce mouvement ainsi que les
entreprises et les assureurs puisque 200
millions d'euros viendront des
assurances pour accompagner les
entreprises je rappelle aussi que ces
mêmes petites entreprises bénéficient du
report des charges sociales et fiscales
et qu'elles peuvent si elles sont en
difficulté de trésorerie immédiatement
demandé des dégrèvements d'impôts
directs
enfin vous m'interpeller sur la
situation du e-commerce par rapport aux
petits commerçants je vais d'abord dire
que 76% des sites de e-commerce voient
leurs ventes baisser plus de la moitié à
hauteur de plus de 50%
donc la situation de consommation elle
manifestement elle s'applique aussi bien
aux e-commerce que aux petits
commerçants je veux également dire que
les petits commerçants peuvent continuer
à vendre en e-commerce nous avons mis en
place toute une série d'instruments à
leur disposition sur le site du
ministère de l'économie et des finances
une offre gratuite ou à des tarifs
préférentiels donné par ces plateformes
de e-commerce
je pense que c'est une très bonne idée
qu'elle aille voir ces dispositifs je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup
l'état de notre collègue laurence
rossignol pour le groupe socialiste et
républicain
la parole de ses collègues merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre j'imagine que vous avez pris
connaissance de l'appel qui a été publié
hier à l'initiative d'une centaine de
médecins qui ont été ensuite rejoint par
le directoire de l'ap-hp dans leur
interpellation et qui est soutenu par de
nombreuses personnalités dans cet appel
propose trois mesures pour garantir
l'accès de toutes les femmes arrivées g
pendant la crise sanitaire parce qu'en
effet ces médecins ont observé que à la
fois le cumul de l'enfermement que
constitue le confinement pour un bon
nombre de femmes mais aussi pour des
jeunes filles pour des mineurs et les
effets des organisateurs de la crise
sanitaire dans les services hospitaliers
met en danger la garantie pour toutes
les femmes d'accéder à une ivg pendant
la crise sanitaire d'autant que nous
n'avons pu le filet de sécurité des
avortements délai à l'étranger puisque
on ne peut pas circuler ces médecins
vous demande de débloquer trois verrous
pendant la durée de la crise
premièrement allongée de deux semaines
le délai légal pour les ivg par
aspiration deuxièmement allongée de deux
semaines le délai légal de lille et j'ai
médicamenteuse troisièmement lever
l'obligation du délai de 48 heures entre
la première consultation et la pratique
de diverger e pour une mineure monsieur
le ministre que répondez vous à ces
trois propositions à cet monsieur le
ministre que répondez vous à ces trois
propositions rien de grave ne vous
inquiétez pas continuer la parole est à
monsieur olivier ferrand
madame la sénatrice laurence rossignol
sans même attendre d'avoir lu la tribune
dont j'ai évidemment pris connaissance
et je m'en suis entretenu avec marlène
schiappa désignèrent suite à votre
première interpellation j'avais active
et mes services je vous confirme que
j'ai des remontées de territoire à
testeurs du fait qu'il y à une réduction
inquiétante du recours à libérer pour
les conditions dans les conditions qui
sont très bien cité dans la tribune et
pour laquelle vous aviez déjà interpellé
la dernière fois je vous avais promis de
regarder le sujet parce que mon
engagement est total sur ce sujet et
vous me donnez l'occasion de vous de
vous répondre sur le fond
aujourd'hui d'abord vous dire très
clairement qu'il est hors de question
que l'épidémie de kobe 19 restreignent
le droit à l'avortement dans notre pays
plusieurs dispositions qui sont à
l'instruction et qui vont être prises
dans les plus brefs délais pour la
plupart d'entre elles d'abord rappelé
que pendant l'épidémie les ivg
médicamenteuses doivent être encouragés
facilité tout en garante en garantissant
un libre choix pour les femmes
j'ai demandé à mes services de
travailler sur une plus grande
utilisation de la téléconsultation que
la première consultation et que la
consultation suivie après prise de la
pilule contraceptive puisse être faite
par télé consultation et non en
présentiel
restera alors la question de la
consultation au cours de laquelle est
délivrer la pilule abortive sur ces
questions là j'ai entendu la demande des
gynécologues de repousser le délai de
réalisation des ivg médicamenteuses en
ville et à domicile de sept à neuf
semaines
on est là sur des questions techniques à
savoir qu'il ne faut pas briser la
chaîne du froid parce que cette pilule
se conserve dans des conditions congelés
et donc nous sommes en train de regarder
ce qu'il est possible de faire sans
prendre de risques dans la chaîne du
médicament mais je le dis je n'ai pas de
d'opposition de principe avec cette
mesure vous dire que les
téléconsultations ont pris un essor
incroyable et que ça devrait permettre
aussi de répondre aux problématiques la
consultation avant et après j'ai demandé
à toutes les équipes des centres ivg et
hospitalière de maintenir le recours à
l'ivg et instrumental enfin sur la
question des recours tardif
nous sommes en train de regarder il
existe une cause de l'interruption
médicale de grossesse donc il ne répond
pas à la question des délais pour des
raisons
de détresse psychosocial et la question
est de savoir dans une décision
collégiale une fois que nous serons
sortis du confinement si effectivement
on peut considérer qu'une jeune femme
qui n'aurait pas pu aller en
consultation pour bénéficier d'un
avortement dans les conditions
classiques peut répondre à ces
conditions de détresse psychosocial vous
avions dit cela vous comprenez ma
position personnelle des réponses très
claires seront apportées à l'ensemble de
ces sujets en lien avec les gynécologues
avec ma collègue marlène schiappa je
remercie en amont chignole si monsieur
le ministre pour vos réponses sur l'île
et j'ai médicamenteuse effectivement je
crois que il ya des perspectives qui
s'ouvrent
la grande bretagne est passée hier à dix
semaines pour les ivg médicamenteuses
même si on peut considérer que ce n'est
pas c'est pas si simple que ça là les vg
médicamenteuse mais c'est quand même la
preuve que c'est possible
en ce qui concerne le lit vg par
aspiration côté monsieur le ministre
quand je vous interpellez ya deux
semaines ici j'avais pas simplement fait
une interpellation j'avais déposé un
amendement qui s'il avait été voté si
vous n'aviez pas émis un avis
défavorable si vous n'aviez pas faire
rejeter mon amendement aurait été
adoptée oui c'est madame pénicaud qui en
votre nom a émis un avis défavorable sur
cet amendement s'il avait été adopté
nous aurions l'allongement du délai
légal de deux semaines on a bien dérogé
au code du travail on a bien dérogé au
code des assurances on pouvait déroger à
tous les codes sauf au code de la santé
publique pour allonger des dix vg je le
regrette profondément parce que j mg ne
sera peut être une solution mais c'est
pas la meilleure des solutions pour les
femmes surtout les mg à la fin du
confinement
merci la parole est à notre collègue
michel laugier pour le groupe de l'union
centriste avait la parole mon cher
collègue tué le président madame et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question au nom du groupe
union centriste porte sur l'absence de
mesures sanitaires à l'accueil des
français rapatriés dans les aéroports
cette question relais une question
écrite que notre collègue olivier cadic
sénateurs représentant les français de
l'étranger vous a posé la semaine
dernière monsieur ministre des
solennités de la santé
depuis ces inquiétudes n'ont cessé de se
confirmer via son réseau qui couvre le
monde entier si dix mille de nos
compatriotes selon le ministère de
l'europe et des affaires étrangères se
battent encore pour se faire rapatrier
et permettez-moi de leur adresse un
message de soutien et de solidarité car
ils se retrouvent parfois dans des
situations bien difficile les cent vingt
mille personnes rentrées depuis deux
semaines dont eu droit à aucune
information à leur arrivée en france
aussi incroyable que cela puisse
paraître aucune mesure spécifique non
cadres le retour des français sur le
territoire national aucune mesure de
protection n'a été mise en place
même si l'arrivée d'un pays à risque on
ne les met pas en quarantaine commun
avait pourtant commencé à le faire avec
les français
revenant de one en chine ont des
intérêts en jeu même pas sur leur
parcours
pas d'information non plus certains ne
savent même pas que nous sommes en
confinement général dont pas
d'injonctions à se confiner eux mêmes à
l'évidence l'état de guerrero sanitaire
n'est pas déclarée dans les aéroports
une réalité qui tranche avec les mesures
prises par de nombreux pays où les
voyageurs sont interrogés sur leur état
de santé et à cliron recommande de se
confiner monsieur le ministre comment se
fait-il que des mesures de rapatriement
si drastiques à l'origine pour ce
revenant de one et plessé la passe un
tel essai à l'est dont les aéroports et
comment justifiez vous que les français
soient confinés mais qu'aucune mesure
sanitaire n'organise la kate de nos
rapatriés pour vous répondre par le
monsieur lui l'idée solidarité de santé
monsieur véran vous avez la parole
monsieur le sénateur logique si vous
interrogez les mille français sont
actuellement dans des caravanes qui sont
revenus par l'espagne du maroc et qui
sont arrivés sur un gros ferries à sète
et qui vous leur demandez si ce que vous
décrivez dans votre question reflète la
réalité je crois qui a mille personnes
qui vous diront que ce n'est pas
vraiment la réalité parce que ces mille
personnes sont confinées dans leur
caravane qu'elles ont reçus
individuellement des consignes prise de
température vérification des conditions
sanitaires leur permettant pour ceux qui
ne présentent pas de simples
d'aller se confiner chez eux et pour
ceux qui présente le moindre symptôme
d'être immédiatement adressé aux 15
allée là la réalité monsieur le sénateur
donc je suis très surpris par la teneur
de cette question je peux comprendre
qu'il ya peut-être des gens qui ont pu
réintégrer le territoire et qui
considèrent qu'il n'aurait pas eu le
juste niveau d'information mais la
réalité et je vous propose d'interroger
focaux l'ex-sénateur de 7 et de ce
magnifique territoire perry
montpelliérains qui vous confirmeront
que le ministre de l'intérieur a mis
tout en oeuvre pour que les conditions
de sécurité sanitaire soient totalement
respectés
ensuite sur les informations apportées à
toutes personnes qui arrivent dans un
aéroport elles sont affichées dans notre
pays depuis le 18 janvier
le 18 janvier beaucoup d'aéroports ont
fermé c'est à dire le cas maintenant
pour orly certains restent ouverts il y
à des services sanitaires qui sont sur
place vingt-quatre heures sur
vingt-quatre 24 heures sur 24 pour
répondre à toute demande d'être capable
de prendre la température et d'adressé
toute personne suspecte d'être malade
directement dans les structures de soins
toutes les conditions d'hygiène les
gestes barrières sont rares sont
affichés en grand format dans toutes les
stations de métro de bus de train et des
aéroports qui fonctionne encore pour
ceux qui fonctionnent encore beaucoup on
fermait s'agissant des aéroports je vous
le disais quant aux conditions de
quarantaine et de confinement chez soi
elles sont elles sont appliquées elles
sont appelées elles sont rappelées à
tout français qui vont sur le territoire
et parfois quand ce sont des arrivées
groupées je reprends une dernière fois
en exemple c'est toi posez leur la
question vous verrez qu encore une fois
la réalité et la pratique elle est là
merci monsieur le premier ministre
madame et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues je veux au nom du sénat
et en mon nom personnel rendre un
hommage particulier à jean louis georges
girard qui a quitté ses fonctions de
secrétaire général du sénat hier au
terme d'une carrière de trente huit
années au service de notre institution
son départ intervient dans les
circonstances si particulière de
l'urgence solitaire à laquelle une
grande partie de l'humanité toujours lui
confronté je peux et je veux témoigner
que jusqu'au bout jean louis se redira
aura été à nos côtés pour piloter
l'administration sénatoriales
à laquelle je rends une nouvelle fois
hommage pour sa réactivité et son
efficacité pour permettre à notre
institution de continuer à tenir toute
sa place à travers la grave crise que
nous traversons et aux sénateurs qu'ils
soient présents ici ou qu'ils nous
regardent ou qui ne nous regarde pas cet
instant d'accomplir leur mission tout au
long de votre carrière jean louis se
retira dans les fonctions diverses
le chef du secrétariat notamment d'une
excellente commission la commission des
affaires économiques et du plan dans vos
fonctions de directeur de mon cabinet de
2008 à 2011
vous avez exercé pendant toutes ces
années
puis pendant deux années et demie au
poste de secrétaire général une fonction
vous avez été chacun le sait une force
de propositions pour adapter notre
organisation exige en vain sénat a les
coudées territoire des citoyens vous
avez qu à la fois vrai réformateur au
delà de la formule de witte à bergues et
un chef de corps apprécié des sénateurs
et de vos collègues
ces dernières semaines vous les avez
passé ici totalement à votre poste
travaillant pour permettre à notre
assemblée de continuer sa mission
constitutionnelle
je voudrais vraiment vous en remercier
l'ensemble des sénateurs se présence
derrière leur écran
ceux qui sont dans leur territoire à
pied d'oeuvre pour faire remonter les
préoccupations de nos concitoyens je le
sais se joignent à moi pour sauver votre
action vous souhaiter bon vent pour
votre vie après le sénat et j'adresse en
votre nom à tous nos meilleurs souhaits
au nouveau secrétaire général du sénat
eric tavernier dont je tiens à dire
qu'après salle du bureau il a toute la
confiance du sénat et des sénateurs
voilà mes chers collègues
à
laver les sols d'applaudissements de la
journée à fond proxité monsieur charles
girard je vais maintenant levé la
science à vous remercier monsieur
premier ministre madame et messieurs les
ministres je crois monsieur le premier
ministre nous nous retrouverons demain
dans une conférence élargie à 9h30 pour
faire un point
prochaines séances le mercredi 8 avril à
15 heures
et j'annonce pour la conférence des
présidents que nous nous réunirons sans
doute la semaine prochaine à une date
que nous déterminerons par consensus les
présidents de groupe soit mardi en fin
d'après-midi soit mercredi en fin de
matinée pour faire un point pour nos
travaux la séance est levée
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement consacrée à
l'épidémie de coronavirus et à la crise
sanitaire les sénateurs ont notamment
interrogé le gouvernement sur les
problèmes d'équipement des hôpitaux
actuellement pendant cette crise
sanitaire et regarder la secrétaire
d'état espagnole une hache et a défendu
et bien l'accélération du gouvernement
notamment et bien pour en citer à la
production d'équipements ecoutez-la 4
milliards d'euros c'est effectivement
l'enveloppent massif qui est aujourd'hui
mise à disposition des hôpitaux pour
permettre de s'approvisionner en
matériel complémentaire mais je crois
que le ministre de la santé a été très
clair sur le plan qui a été anticipé et
mis en oeuvre depuis le début de cette
crise pour approvisionner l'ensemble des
hôpitaux l'ensemble des centres
hospitaliers à un moment où les
consommations de masques de gel
hydroalcoolique deux médicaments sont
multipliées par dix parfois par sens
parfois par mille au plan mondial
donc le sujet n'est pas avalé
réquisitionnés ou d'aller nationaliser
ce n'est pas ça qui va permettre de
fabriquer plus de masques ou plus de gel
hydroalcoolique le sujet aujourd'hui
c'est d'entraîner notre industrie comme
nous sommes en train de le faire comme
nous sommes en train de le faire en
ayant porté la production de masse
de 13 5 millions en france à plus de 40
millions au mois d'avril
comme nous sommes en train de le faire
en mobilisant le réseau d'achat
notamment santé publique france qui a
acheté plus d'un milliard de masques et
aujourd'hui qui est étayée par des
acheteurs privés
près de 150 qui sont en appui pour
équiper l'ensemble des français et comme
nous sommes également en train de le
faire avec le gel hydroalcoolique
puisque nous avons multiplié par dix par
10 la production de gel hydroalcoolique
et nous allons construire en 50 jours
autant de respirateurs que la france en
a produit en trois ans lors du serait
donc mobilisés dans cette crise
sanitaire les citoyens français le sont
également et pour en parler j'accueille
galerie à la tall secrétaire d'état
auprès du ministre de l'éducation
bonjour gabriel et al alors vous l'avez
annoncé durant cette séance de questions
avec des questions d'actualité deux cent
cinquante mille français se sont
déclarés volontaires pour participer à
la réserve civique qu'ovide 19
quels sont les besoins de cette réserve
civique est ce que vous avez des
chiffrages sur sur les besoins
on a réuni très tôt avec jean michel
blanquer olivier ferrand christelle
dubost les grands réseaux associatifs
pour identifier avec eux les besoins il
ya des actions associatives qui ont pu
être suspendu l'essentiel d'entre elles
le confinement mais il ya des actions
qui sont vitales notamment l'aide
alimentaire aux plus démunis le lien
avec les personnes vulnérables et
isolées et pour cela il ya besoin d'eux
or dit les associations c'est que en % à
50 % de leurs bénévoles réguliers
habituels ont plus de 70 ans est donc
évidemment ils leur ont demandé de
rester confinés chez eux le plus souvent
possible et donc de suspendre leur
activité bénévole c'est autant de bras
qu'il faut trouver pour permettre au
libre aux services sociaux aux points de
distribution des restos du coeur
d'ouvrir et d'avoir leur activité qui
est absolument vital donc 250 mille
français
c'est un élan de solidarité absolument
exceptionnel et inédit ont rejoint la
réserve civique cinquante mille d'entre
eux sont déjà engagés dans une mission
d'autres missions sont en train
d'arriver progressivement sur la
plateforme moi j'appelle les
associations et les collectivités
locales qui ont des besoins de renforts
bénévoles à les déclarer sur la
plateforme
maintenant l'important je continue à le
dire c'est de rester chez soi il s'agit
pas de sortir pour sortir s'agit de
sortir quand c'est nécessaire pour des
activités associatives qui sont vitales
pour beaucoup de français
et on a besoin pour cela de cette
mobilisation alors un bel exemple de
solidarité
vous le disiez mes dents mais dans le
même temps plus de la moitié des
français ne font pas confiance au
président de la république emmanuel
macron pour gérer cette crise sanitaire
comment vous expliquez cette défiance
dans un moment en inquiétude chez les
français et c'est légitime moi je
l'entends totalement les français sont
inquiets se pose des questions et c'est
tout à fait normal ce que je peux dire
moi de ce que je vois dans la majorité
ce que je vaux au gouvernement c'est que
le gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé
qui fait du mieux qu'il peut pour cette
crise et pour relever est alors dans
cette crise sanitaire est ce que les
responsables politiques d'opposition
doivent critiqué la gestion sanitaire du
gouvernement
moi je considère que concept politique
et fonder légitime à poser des questions
et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que j'ai été
ici avec le premier ministre avec des
collègues ministres pour répondre aux
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
pour ça que le premier ministre est mon
collègue olivier ferrand seront
auditionnés à l'assemblée nationale tout
à l'heure c'est légitime pour des
représentants de la nation de poser des
questions sur la manière dont cette
crise et affronter très bien merci
beaucoup à la gabriela talent d'avoir
répondu à mes questions et je vais
maintenant accueillir bruno retailleau
le président du groupe l'est républicain
au sénat
alors bruno retailleau on a parlé dans
cette séance de questions d'actualité
et bien déjà de la praye confinement de
la sortie de la période de confinement
avec une accélération notamment de la
production de test des tests rapides
sérologique qui vont également être
produit comment on fait pour sortir de
cette période de confinement est ce
qu'il faut être prudent et la faire
durer assez longtemps
d'abord on essaie d'avoir un coup
d'avancé parce que souvent aujourd'hui
on a eu le sentiment d'avoir un coup de
retard sur le dépistage massif et puis
sur les masques c'est fondamental la
sortie du confinement parce que ça va
définir si oui ou non on aura une
seconde vague pour le virus avec encore
des morts dont on croit que c'est
important
c'est maintenant qu'on la prépare
il faut vraiment que enfin on puisse
anticiper nous avons proposé avec
catherine de roche du reste on n'a pas
eu de réponse pour l'instant que
laboratoire d'analysé dans les
départements vous savez dans les
départements on a 75 structures qui sont
extrêmement pointus notamment en terme
de recherche peut en berne notamment d'
analyse et il faut les mobiliser et pour
l'instant ils n'ont pas l'autorisation
et je pense que le moment est venu je le
dis solennellement il faut qu' on puisse
bousculer la technocratie la
bureaucratie française
il faut faire ce pas justement si on
reste totalement coincé dans des vieux
schémas et là on a besoin de tout le
monde
le déconfinement la sortie du
confinement ne se fera que si on est
capable d'avoir un dépistage massif et
notamment sérologique voir quelle partie
de la population est immunisée qu'on ne
pourra pas le faire si on ne mobilise
pas de toutes les troupes alors on
parler du dépistage parlons maintenant
des traitements ces dernières semaines
vous avez défendu la molécule
chloroquine et notamment la
généralisation de ce traitement mais ces
derniers jours on voit qu'il ya des
effets secondaires indésirables dans les
patients qui prennent de la chloroquine
parfois même des cas mortels
est ce qu'il faut quand même rester
prudent avec la chloroquine non mais un
médicament il faut jamais le prendre à
la légère
moi j'ai jamais demandé la
généralisation j'ai toujours demandé
qu'on puisse d'abord utilisé en milieu
hospitalier
et puis ensuite en médecine de ville
mais toujours prescrits par des médecins
simplement qu'on voit bien qu'un certain
nombre d'études comme en direct montre
que la chloroquine est importante
notamment parce qu'elle permet de ne pas
passer d'une forme peu sévère c'est à
dire bening à une forme beaucoup plus
grave et il faut pas là encore là aussi
il faut pas qu'ils aient une
bureaucratie qui puisse si j'ose dire
nous empêcher d'avancer
de toute façon quel est le traitement
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
le traitement alternatif on en a pas en
la chloroquine on connaît les
contre-indications cardiaque et autres
vous savez si vous êtes aujourd'hui par
exemple allergique à l'aspirine vous
prenez de l'aspirine et vous allez faire
un deuxième de quick donc chaque
médicament doit être prescrit avec un
médecin
des contre indications mais ne nous
privons pas je pense de cette molécule
associé à à une autre notamment en
matière d'antibiotiques
c'est comme le professeur jure qu'est ce
qu'on a à perdre puisque on a des vies
humaines
aujourd'hui qui malheureusement sont
mises en danger on a des morts
je crois que là aussi un certain nombre
d'études mais il faut les accélérer et
là encore te grâce pas de bureaucratie
voilà pas de chicaya avec des querelles
d'ego je pense que il est important
maintenant de se saisir aussi de toutes
les opportunités à condition évidemment
que ces opportunités ne présente pas de
trop de risques dernière question à
bruno retailleau le président de la
république hier un peu dénoncé les
critiques contre son gouvernement dans
la gestion de cette crise sanitaire
il a notamment dénoncé ceux qui veulent
faire un procès au gouvernement alors
que nous n'avons même pas gagné à cette
guerre sanitaire est ce que les
opposants politiques au gouvernement ou
le droit de critiquer sa gestion non
mais moi je pense je crois à l'unité
nationale
je ne suis pas de ceux qui vont se
lancer dans des procès aujourd'hui alors
qu'il faut gagner une bataille d'une
guerre encore une fois je pense que le
président de république ne doit pas dans
ses discours
comment dirais-je faire la leçon aux uns
ou aux autres on attend qu'il soit le
père de la nation
je pense qu'il n'a pas intérêt justement
à souligner ses divisions probable nous
on a un devoir justement de
responsabilité qui est ce devoir d'unité
mais le devoir d'unité
il va avec le devoir de vérité je pense
que les français ont du bon sens et on
doit et le gouvernement doit aussi des
réponses aux questions que se posent
légitimement des français donc bien sûr
devoir d'unité mais aussi vigilance et
nous sommes ici au sénat le relais des
questions que se posent aujourd'hui tous
nos compatriotes
merci beaucoup bruno retailleau d'avoir
répondu à mes questions et je vais
maintenant accueillir le président du
groupe centriste au sénat hervé
marseille après cette séance de
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
consacrée aux coronavirus et à cette
crise sanitaire bonjour hervé marseille
alors durant cette séance il a été aussi
question des assurances et de leur rôle
soutenir les entreprises dans la crise
économique qui va se dérouler face au
cours d'un virus et ce qu'il faut être
plus ferme avec les assurances avec le
monde de la finance pour
et bien mettre la main au portefeuille
et soutenir l'économie à l'évidence il
faut aussi penser à la sortie de la
crise parce qu'aujourd'hui les français
c'est mental mais aussi penser à ce qui
va se passer dans quelques semaines on
voit bien que de très nombreuses
entreprises on est en grande difficulté
le chômage va augmenter il ya beaucoup
de feu de deux français qui vont
souffrir également sur le plan financier
et donc il faut penser à toutes ces pme
c'était pe toutes ces professions
libérales qui aujourd'hui sont au bord
de la route et qui vont souffrir
alors le gouvernement a mis en place un
certain nombre de dispositifs c'est
important mais ce n'est pas encore
suffisant il faut davantage de
précisions pour y avoir accès on voit
bien que les conditions d'accès il ya
embouteillage parce que tout le monde
essaie d'accéder par les moyens
numériques qu'il a à sa disposition et
qui sont inégaux suivant les endroits où
on se trouve parce qu'il ya aussi des
zones blanches toujours dans ce pays
et c'est dans ces périodes qu'on se rend
compte de façon vraiment préoccupante
donc les assurances comme les
entreprises qui elles fonctionnent bien
doivent être mis à contribution il ya
des entreprises qui profitent de la
crise on voit bien et donc cette
inégalité il faut que ceux qui vont bien
ou ceux qui sont là pour protéger ma
paye pour ceux qui vont mal et ce qu'il
faut mettre également à contribution les
plus fortunés par exemple gérald
darmanin a fait un appel aux dons une
sorte de corona ton pour et bien
soutenir l'effort national je crois pas
que ce soit au niveau et à la hauteur
je pense qu'il faut trouver des
solutions qui soient plus adaptée qui
soit plus en rapport avec ce qu'est la
france je veux dire on a des offres
importantes celles là sont épargnés
souvent elles ont une part de capital
national je pense avec des f a l'air
france ou d'autres grandes entreprises
là c'est l'état qui devra massivement
intervenir pour les protéger en revanche
moi je pense surtout à toutes ces
petites entreprises celles qui
constituent le têt le tissu économique
de notre pays qui créent l'emploi et qui
demain vont être en grande difficulté et
non pas de trésorerie et donc la
première chose à faire c'est non pas de
reporter mais d'annuler les charges
qu'elles doivent payer parce que elles
n'ont pas pu travailler en mars et n'ont
pas pu travailler vraisemblablement en
avril pourront difficilement travailler
en mai donc ce n'est pas en reportant
les charges qu'on va les aider il va
falloir un moment donné annuler ses
charges
parce que si on veut créer un appel
d'air si on veut les aider eh bien il
faut aller à l'annulation et non pas au
report est pourquoi le gouvernement
refuse d'annuler tout de suite ses
charges
je pense que le gouvernement travaille à
l'évaluation parce qu'on a déjà dépend
beaucoup d'argent c'était nécessaire et
je pense qu'il faut savoir de quelle
évaluation parle de quelle date à quelle
date également de quel type d'entreprise
ce ne peut pas être toutes les
entreprises encore une fois il ya les
importantes elles sont certainement
aussi leurs difficultés
c'est pas du même niveau si mon public
avec quelques salariés ou à ces pme qui
sont dans les villages et villes de
france et qui souffrent aujourd'hui qui
sont à l'arrêt alors versé à une
question sur les élus locaux les élus
locaux payent un lourd tribut durant
cette crise sanitaire
beaucoup de communes ont perdu leur mère
à cause du courant navires us beaucoup
d'élus ont disparu c'est dû à la
campagne municipale
c'est en tout cas dû au fait qu'ils sont
en première ligne parce que quand il ya
une crise comme celle là et on l'avait
vu qu'une autre crise qui était celle
des gels et jaune ceux qui sont devant
ceux qui sont en première ligne
ce sont pour l'état les préfets et pour
le terrain des mères la vie française
c'est bien sûr l'armée la police la
gendarmerie mais c'est surtout les
maires et les préfets qui sont en
première ligne
les élus et aux contacts la population
ils sont toujours là la maison commune
ce serait une petite ville une grande
ville c'est vers les élus qu'on se
tourne
parce que c'est la proximité c'est eux
qui apportent des réponses ils paient le
tribut et je pense notamment mon ami
patrick devedjian qui est décédé il ya
quelques jours patrick devedjian
président du département des
hauts-de-seine et ancien ministre merci
beaucoup y en a d'autres
et oui il y en a d'autres merci beaucoup
mais marseille d'avoir répondu à mes
questions et je vais maintenant
accueillir la sénatrice communiste du
pas-de-calais cathy apourceau poly
bonjour bonjour cathy apourceau poly
alors vous avez interroger le
gouvernement
aujourd'hui sur et bien les problèmes
d'équipement des hôpitaux le manque de
masquer le manque de respirateurs le
manque de test et la ministre anne
espagne est revenu chez vous a répondu
en vous expliquant que la réquisition de
l'industrie pharmaceutique ce n'était
pas la solution
oui évidemment c'est ce qu'elle pense en
tous les cas j'ai demandé évidemment que
l' on réquisitionne et que l'on
nationalise les entreprises
oui on énorme tous les jours il n'y a
pas une journée où nous n'avons pas de
ds ou est ce de la part de soignants
soit les eaux ou des pharmaciens les
médecins les infirmières ils n'ont pas
de matériel
aujourd'hui il nous faut de l'oxygène il
du curragh il nous faudrait il nous faut
nation merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
à force au poly c'est la fin de cette
émission spéciale de pour les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement
ici au sénat je voudrais remercier
toutes les équipes de public sénat sur
place et à distance qui ont rendu
possible cette émission et puis pour
continuer à vous informer sur cette
crise sanitaire
n'hésitez pas à aller sur notre site
internet publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée sur public sénat
[Musique]